[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up guys
Eric here I'm back if you were watching
the titanfall 2 stream here earlier with
me and Rob that has ended obviously and
now we're gonna go on to our Diablo 3
necromancer stream the necromancer pack
is out today
I think it's been out at least on PC for
about two hours now it came out a little
earlier than expected but we're gonna
check her out
him or her depending on which one I
decided to make was hoping to get some
name suggestions from you people
otherwise I'm gonna call my necro old
guy or old lady necromancer pack was
$14.99 you could purchase that in the PC
well I'm playing on PC right now so I
purchased that in the game where I when
it opened up it was like hey necromancer
is out do you want to buy it so for
$14.99 you're getting the necromancer
class a non-combat pet a pair of
cosmetic wings which I'll show off in a
little bit new necromancer themed banner
shape signal and accent necromancer
necromancer portrait frame a pennant to
additional character slots and two
additional stash tabs but the stash tabs
are only on PC those two additional
stash tabs won't be on console also with
this necromancer pack I guess 2.6 has
come out which gives us challenger rifts
some new areas the shouted Mors own
temple the firstborn zone and the realms
of the fate those are all part of the
update you don't need the necromancer
pack necessarily for that but that's
also out today and I guess the only
other thing I can mention is if you
haven't bought this game at all for
console there is a new Diablo 3 eternal
collection that will give you the
necromancer and everything else before I
think right now for a special price of
like 39.99 otherwise I'm seeing some
names already call her is that zania
death Queen seeing some names hello to
everyone in YouTube and twitch chat
viper games lou william pagan heart
and everyone joining us if you haven't
already followed us on twitch please do
that that'd be awesome and if you
haven't subscribed to us on youtube yet
that also be awesome so you know when we
go live for live streams and also when
we make that awesome VOD content just
started playing alright so I'm gonna go
a female necro cuz that's new can do
that in d2 so far I only have one name
request and I can't fit that so it'd
have to be death clean or zania if I
could spell queen or zania or dark rose
I've gotten to I kid hybrid it go death
rose or dark queen what's up Diego I'm
Justin marks are saying color conky
konkey dong what's up Bob so yes this is
sort of like yeah it's essentially DLC
George or Jorge alright let's just go
with it doesn't matter
we're gonna go death rose I guess it was
a hybrid of both now the next question
is do you guys want me to do story
because they did change up some of the
voice lines in story to fit that now
that the necros in there or we can just
do a venture mode and check out the new
zones death rose is a terrible name dark
mistress there's too many names what do
you guys want do you want to see the new
zones in a venture mode or do you guys
want a story I'm sorry the naming phases
has done I guess you guys are gonna take
a second here with the delay to tell me
which thing you want
I think it's on console 2x jet XG xgm
I'm not totally sure I got one vote for
story I'll give another 30 seconds
before you guys to decide
it's looking like story right now now
one adventure alright the next one that
tiebreaks it is what I'm gonna go at
it's one one right now
whoa Adventure story story news Owens
adventure okay
um go with adventure since that seems to
be more I saw some campaign and some
story while it's coming in hot okay I'll
do some story after how about that oh
there's a lot of story all right hold on
here we'll do adventure real quick we'll
check out a new zone with like no skills
I think it's an act tunic for there you
go temple the first worn all right I got
like bone spike and normal attack so we
got cockroaches those are new I should
probably lower that a bit okay I could
also choose this a little bit but I'm
not going to I think technically I think
since there's no season right now I
could transfer gear over but we'll just
play like from base like starting all
over we we now have bone spike which is
good pickup that's the one fun thing
that I feel like is like when you start
all over is you can feels good to pick
up any loot especially when you don't
have any thing at all blue this pretty
dark digging the dark aesthetic so those
corpses have you seen them when we get
corpse explode we can use those later
there's other other skills as well that
will kind of use that use those corpses
and that was that's a new thing in the
game obviously okay maybe we should go
to expert I'm only playing on a hard
right now
new events poison so this is one of the
new areas the temple of the firstborn I
think there's a Boston here it said
there was so we'll see what that boss is
see what happens
alright I guess this is the one ending
these bosses something's a bunch of
stuff and also does jailor pretty
annoying
I don't want to be next sir Wow she goes
um sent keys to all right we got her
got some gathering shoes that's good oh
cool we got corpse explode so like it
just does like an area and the more
corpses obviously the better
necros mana or what not a spring is
called essence I think corpse explode is
one of the cooler looking abilities that
the necro has well I'm off more as we go
I'll try my best to reach out as well
someone telling me to do torment one I
don't think I could do torment one heart
is so easy I could bump it I guess we
could try torment one and then see how
it goes but I don't want to like
struggle too much because obviously
they'll be boring for you guys to watch
me not being able to kill stuff but I
guess we could bump it up after this
area and check out the next one on a
harder difficulty because we could
always scale it down which is a good
thing can I raise the dead yes I can but
not right now because I don't have the
ability yet but when I got the ability
I'll raise some dead for you guys right
now we just got corpse explode bone
spike and bones here trying to get some
we need some new gear though
so the necro has you know obviously its
own main hand and off hand as well and
it also has like a two-handed scythe I
think as a new kind of like weapon type
guess that axe is quite better than this
sickle or what not gonna move I'll bump
up the difficulty though uh what Paragon
is this account I guess this one's 704 I
could also cheat in that regard and use
Paragon but I feel like we should just
have a actual like brand new experience
so I won't do that so I guess we could
do skeletal mage skeletal mages like on
a timer
so I don't like you summon it and then
it like shows up it does some spells and
some damage and then it eventually will
go away like that first one disappeared
but you can keep casting them I think we
can halves it by yeah it's five glad it
wasn't a wire there so the stoning the
skeletal mages cost us like what is it
forty essence yeah right now have 200
there are passes of course to get more
essence but it's only fifty but yeah if
yeah will gets more complex and more fun
once you get to kind of like the endgame
and to that to the loot getting those
set bonuses and whatnot Massacre things
cool too but that was that wasn't in
this update that was uh earlier kind of
sad though that they didn't have a new
season with the release of the necro but
maybe they wanted to kind of have necro
come out let people play it maybe
balance it a bit they did have a beta
for a bit as well if you were able to
get into that
check out this stuff yeah maybe hards a
little too easy kind of like easy though
you know less less room to fail
I guess we could have made hardcore too
but then if I was playing hardcore i
definitely wouldn't ramp up the
difficulty right now
also if the audio is not loud enough
game audio or anything just tell me and
I can adjust that a lot of cultists they
are channeling some type of blood thing
it's not cool all right guess we killed
enough cultists and filled the room with
blood - then open the door that's pretty
cool that's I'm new what do we just get
okay we got a sudden impact that were
chance it's done okay cool
oh yeah let's uh I should put on those
wings huh
so these wings the wings of the Crypt
guardian is what you get as a bonus if
you purchased the pack as well as this
half-formed golem that's all Sony you
see they're supposed to be like a necro
portrait I believe it's probably is it
this one no it's this one yeah and then
there's a pennant which let's see lore
master let's try this one
Blood master so I have equipped a bunch
of the stuff that came with the pack if
you are looking into buying it or
purchasing it that's a lot more damage
so the wings look pretty cool kind of
look a little bit similar to the
Kerrigan ones when you bought a heart of
the swarm but little bit I don't know
more natural feel to it I guess yeah
thank you to chat I think not only
colloid before but everyone that's a
kind of filling in others in terms of
like answering questions and what and I
appreciate it come on resplendent all
right we need that stuff need it
getting rares feels good when you're
when you're broke it's live in the u.s.
you can play it I'm not sure about
console but I am currently playing PC
and that is definitely available weird
all right I guess this is one of the new
bosses or something awkward we're
getting much closer
I guess corpse explode is not as up
Wow quarks exploit it like no damage ooh
New York's New York's already that would
be really good if it's leoric's okay got
unique helm or a legendary home New
York's is good because experience we
just need to get a ruby so obviously
that's good so that was one of the new
zones everyone wants me to bump up the
difficulty so I'm gonna leave real quick
and then bump it up pull up pelipper
regrets buying diablo 3 too much
grinding the same places over and over
again I feel like Diablo 3 the the base
game wasn't as good as it could have
been and but with Reaper of souls and
all of the subsequent like patches and
updates they the game got a lot better
quality of life as well as like other
things like kanai's cube but that was
also huge also altered gameplay quite a
bit so yeah NASCO that was just I'm
playing an adventure mode but that was
one of the new zones the temple of the
firstborn now we're gonna check out I
think it's act for that there's another
area upper I spy this one upper realm of
the infernal fate oh there's a bunch of
okay so all four of these areas are new
I guess that as well whoa there's a lot
those weren't there before
I guess we'll check this one out also
the story is a little bit different
because there's new like audio and stuff
like that which we'll check out in a bit
sorry I don't worry I am working on just
playing alright let's see how bad this
is gonna do you okay I don't think we
can be pulling that one guys not with
like just low level bass here so let's
slow it see if we can do master usually
I'm pretty sure like with no gear to
start and with me not putting any points
into my Paragon we probably can't do
higher than like expert until we get my
gear otherwise it's gonna be really slow
like you're seeing right now if I lower
it again unfortunately because this is
probably way more boring for you guys to
see me like spamming blowing spike on
one mob father pretty sure this should
be okay though or at least manageable
twice so very fast
personally - is this all a game and
another game that if you're playing a
RPGs right now that's a really really
solid game is a path of Exile they have
really good updates and they have like
seasons and ladders and whatnot and
races races are pretty cool races are a
cool concept I'm actually surprised that
Diablo hasn't embraced something like
that at some point so here's the neck of
phylactery necro is having you often
gube there's not much for me to show
skill tree wise because we don't have
that many skills and points to allocate
so I'll do that as we go as we get new
skills and whatnot because this because
like through beta and whatnot the skills
are kind of been revealed so you're
looking for just like skill tree tea and
stuff I would just take a look at that
stuff and I kind of show people the
gameplay of skill wise what we have so
far
I appreciate you chiming in
appreciate all you guys watching tuning
in to necro class new class out in
Diablo 3
so far we just have three skills perps
explode or actually that's not true we
just got a new skill yeah I want to see
high level skills well if I'm not gonna
see him right now because I just started
and because I'm not really gonna use my
Paragon points and stuff like that
because I want to experience like a base
level necro you're not gonna see too
many of that stuff right now
unfortunately so I apologize
sticky chicken saying he's gonna go
Bloods back one seems pretty interesting
I know that from the stuff I've read and
heard a little bit blood as a endgame
SPECT wasn't very good there seems to be
only like two of the four sets that are
seemed viable for endgame which is kind
of how Oh also if you guys noticed I
have command skeletons now so they'll
just Auto summon skeletons and you can
command them to attack a specific but
yeah blood I heard was not super hot for
endgame but you know maybe you can make
it work or maybe you're not the type of
person that's trying to min/max in which
case there's a lot of specs that you can
go to just have fun with the game it's
just if you're trying to push greater
rifts or anything like that then blood
might be a hard spec to go but I think
the concept of blood and using your
health and whatnot in cash your spell's
and then that also then kind of affects
how you play maybe you're you're
expecting into some gear that has like
regen or life on hit and stuff like that
kind of
balance out you using your health as
mana or essence really do you enjoy the
course explode
I get here's a question for the chat as
well for a lot of those people that
either have played Diablo 3 we're
thinking about it I'm curious if any of
you guys played Diablo 2 and if you
played a necro then because I didn't
really play necro in Diablo 2 I played a
lot of like pally and wizard so curious
if any of you guys played any of these
other specs I'm just gonna check out
some of these other realms I don't know
if they're any that much different yeah
season 11 will be July than 20th so yeah
Kamui saying that he's gonna be playing
blood and bones beer personally only
because I dislike meta builds okay
and he kept that druid I don't think
anyone wants a druid man David the dude
assassin was a cool class though both
were trapped assassin as well as a
secular combat with a was a tiger claw
and tiger kick
teleporting necro with bone says pumps 1
1k yeah we're will get a skill called
blood rush in a little bit that lets us
kind of teleport and it's a pretty cool
skill it's kind of like you'd get a get
away skill as well as like a movement
cool movement skill
also I guess another part of it too is
if you did play Diablo 2 how many
potential like Diablo 2 remake I really
thought that they would maybe announce
it like a taboo spawn or something for
the 20th anniversary but did not come to
fruition unfortunately and I don't even
know if it's still gonna happen I just
think I want to say my friend sent me
this Blizzard post that had like the job
specs for it but not sure how legit that
was oh I have an active or passive so we
can get fueled by deaths consuming of
course increases your movement or
consuming so I guess we'll just go for
movement since it doesn't seem like
we're having too much trouble surviving
right now but again we're only playing
expert don't think I was having problems
surviving as much as I was having
problems killing things at like master
in format one I agree with that cool
saying in YouTube chat I think Diablo 3
looks far better and stories far better
but in terms of gameplay grinding Diablo
2 is better I agree with that
and I kind of liked having more than six
kills to be honest but we have Gollum
now I guess we could give up corpse
explode if you guys want to see us kind
of going full pets back in a way so
there's our baseball and there's
obviously different versions of that and
he'll look slightly different depending
on which one we have and the cool thing
about this golem versus like the Diablo
2 golem is that he has like an active
ability that you can use to like I send
them
he creates like a pile of corpses which
would be good if I still had perfect
road but
yeah does the gameplay feel a similar to
a witch doctor um back to no one I think
a little bit there are certain things
that make the neck go feel different
from the witch doctor but I was a you
know I've never personally been a huge
fan of the necro and so it was kind of
interesting to see them add it like
another summoner class when they already
had one but there are a lot of people
that also just really love the necro
from Diablo 2 might maybe they didn't
enjoy the witch doctor as much and
wanted more of this you know the dark
arts and blood magic and bone and sinew
type type of aesthetic so I could see
why the necro was like kind of like a
popular pick I guess
yeah I guess the you I mean like you can
kind of compare the goal until it's like
to the car or van Xuan from the witch
doctor but I don't think the gargantuan
has too much active ability right like I
know that depending on which one you
pick you know he might go frenzied if
you know there's like an elite or
something but it's kind of cool that the
the golems and the skeletons do have
active abilities that like you can
command and do things with where's the
witch doctor you didn't really have that
I guess so that's kind of like the one
big difference like I can tell my
skeletons like hey attack that guy you
know same with my colon a necro should
be out today as well I believe I think
it's more contingent on when you know
Playstation or Xbox does they're like
updates because that's when the updates
and whatnot will show up for you guys
but you might already be out actually
I'm just playing on PC so I just can't
100% verify for you guys if it's out on
console but if anyone is either playing
console or thinking about playing
console and can chime in if it's
actually out that'd be awesome
I would appreciate so with the rest of
chat good to see you regeneration nation
thanks for stopping by how much is the
deal sees a new coach asking it is $15
you get the deal seat the neck row
basically is a classic okay guys as I
looked over two chapters again so you
get the neck row which is like the big
part of this and then you get oh I just
trapped myself I need blood rush and
then you get these wings that I have the
icon logo portrait thing at the top left
which I'm also using and then you get a
banner you get two additional character
slots as well as two stashed abs if
you're on PC wow this is a lot harder
than just now for some reason I guess
it's also because there's a rare mom
over there because I don't have
perfect word
it's already playing this morning says
Michael I think sorry if I butchered
your last name it said he's loving it
awesome
so there's definitely some fans for the
necro and for those that didn't get to
get in the bait I'm sure this is a
pretty cool day for myself never
understood why people like this style of
games doesn't mean any of business RPGs
are fun I think that certain like for
myself I enjoy the grinding I enjoy
upgrading gear there are definitely
certain aspects that can be repetitive
but some people like that repetitive
nature and I think that's why it's
that's part of the beauty of videogames
you know there's different games for
different people and if this isn't your
cup of tea then you know you can play a
racing game to play an RPG you could
play an FPS it's a bunch of stuff so
yeah this isn't for you that's fine
let's see if there's any other places
that I'm missing here I don't think so
though it's mainly those two areas
it's a $15 also for whoever was asking
[Music]
yeah also like Firenze earrings up a
good point it's like value proposition
how much time do you think you're gonna
spend for the 15 dollars you know if you
think you're gonna spend you know even
five hours on it I think that's pretty
good for me but you know it's always
subject to the person right
there is not a new Act though Jay Tibbs
fourteen there's just some new zones and
story got redundant bits
there's challenge rifts but I haven't
gone through all the story I showed one
of the new zones just now I guess now we
have decrepit by which I might change
the discourse explode I think give us a
little bit of deep because I feel like
we're lacking in the beeps right now and
we can't change that yet of course this
is still in combat
so no command skelton abilities that's
risen mages will leave behind a corpse
that's good
I can also try death Nova if you guys
want to see that yeah we tried death
Nova so you guys can see what that looks
like hey Fox trust me I've lived both
worlds it depends on like like how you
wanna like if there different kinds of
games with different kinds of grinds or
maybe similar kinds of grinds but
different kinds of games but destiny is
like an FPS that I don't know I feel
like is an even funner experience with
more people playing with your friends
and whatnot hopping on chat which I do
as well in Diablo but I feel like you
can also play this game kind of
single-player which is like part of the
reason why there's a lot of people that
enjoy it so yeah
a story got redone up it in the sense
that like I know that necro like I don't
think that much of the story itself
actually changed as much as it is
adapting the necro into the story so
like the necro and interactions and
voice lines and stuff like that changed
but yeah I mean we can go through some
stories some people were asking for that
so we could technically go through that
if you guys want as well if does if you
guys want to see some story stuff we can
go through that just writing in chat and
we can switch mode the story mode
otherwise I'm just checking out some of
the newer zones these this one's the
fractured fate keeps of death so it's
like a variation of the keeps death
keeps depths
riffs was a pretty big deal to Don't Ask
Don't Tell in terms of like coming back
to Diablo like I said if you started
with Diablo 3 and then didn't play it
for like a while like there's some
definitely some cool stuff that they've
added I think also what's different
about these fractured areas is that like
it you know like we just went from the
keep steps to now being in the festering
woods and the part of what the
difference is
OOP shrine oh thanks April par allow
1481 saying this game is cool and I sub
thank you for seven remember guys and
gals we are streaming on YouTube and
twitch so if you are around and have not
array subscribe to follow us we'd really
appreciate it so you guys know when
we're going live when we're putting up
like you know other geography content or
other games that we can you know play
you get some time fall to this morning
really fun that was a new update
attached that came out this is a new
weapon yep a lot more damage that's good
I just want to see a lot of green when
you're starting off sticky chicken
saying in a hopefully 30 minutes it'll
be out in Europe I hope it is for you
guys as well if it's not already out
but you guys can also enjoy in on some
necro fun well I appreciate you guys
tuning in for the next 30 minutes or so
then I'm out
Death Note was a pretty cool skill it's
like I know I don't think I can't think
of a skill that the witch doctor has
that that resembles that skill cool
yeah I just feel like in general in
terms of like the pet stuff if there's a
little bit more because of the active
skills it's a little bit more fun
because they're actually like doing
stuff you're actually commanding your
pets I go
there's any other abilities who saw that
you want me to try out I can do that as
well
consul hot if Rob is in here if he isn't
they are streaming the master trials on
Friday him and Peter if you haven't
played this and you were thinking about
playing it on console there's a pretty
good like I think it's called the
eternal edition Diablo through eternal
Edition which has everything up to the
necromancer patch so it's pretty good
forty dollars right now as part of like
the I don't know if I want to call it
the early bird special but that won't be
there forever
the only thing I think you don't get
that I or that you would get on PC is
that they have to extra stash tab which
for some reason isn't in the console
version only
and now we're back out in the
battlefield she's stupid poison guys are
like the worst these the weird hentai
armed guys and these guys
most aidid but bees for sure are like
number one number one most hated enemy
type in the same try a new generator all
right let's do that
we can try grim sight which is like a
big like oh this one's small for some
reason bursar reduces the essence cause
that's good we can have some major that
do poisons let's do that I'll keep
trying to keep me honest guys keep keep
having me change skills so I guess if
you summon this meat skeletal made it
just does it like a poison Nova that
keeps pulsing in that area I've switched
to grim site that's my generator my
essence generator please show blood
style says X deaths easy I'll show blood
style once we get more skills for it
again like we're level 17 right now so
as we get the skills I will try to do my
best to showcasing new stuff I think
there's a blood Nova so I don't know
what level that is at key under eyes
Evans I from what I can tell it seems
like it did come out a little bit
earlier in the US and it did in other
regions because some people here are
saying Europe's not out for 30 more
minutes
si si I'll try to get as many minutes as
possible I don't think I get revived for
like a while yeah revived so it revives
at 22 that's actually not that far away
well who is in stealth will may just
seem not back because they do AoE yeah
so you could kind of go more like a
melee manager style you're like oh God
you know like death Nova is not the way
to go with the rest of those skills I'm
using this possum like wait for my
passing
Kalidas 89 brings up a good point again
guys just know that like I understand
that some people think that maybe like
cooking oh my god I just got ground
pounded $15 could seem like you know
like a bit of money and again it's like
different value propositions for
different people and you know like is
$15 gonna get you you know how much time
are you gonna spend if you're gonna play
it a lot you know it's it's totally
gonna be worth it I don't dream site is
so bad for this
okay sucks good ass wander inside was
like a way bigger
I shouldn't have done that actually crap
come on
I can't believe they can punt back my
skeletal mesh that's kind of dumb
I have I definitely died there
these guys hurt man mallets Lords are no
joke I mean it's easy to dodge one guy
but like when we're on a little bridge
here a lot harder
skip eat supper today and you can afford
nectar oh yeah or like I said you go
watch a movie it's almost the same like
nowadays if you watch a movie it's
almost as much as like flying this DLC
so Dustin Mumma is saying that he would
like to see the assassin return I would
too but the monk is probably kind of
like what they're like a weird hybrid of
a you know
yeah that's really annoying that they
can knock back the skeletal mage all
right Brian
can we got a new golem and possibly a
new grim side so I'll see if we can get
some of these skills here so command the
goal on the tart collapses into a pile
stop
stop it guys feel like you already does
that
oh you can get skeletal archers instead
of mages
I mean depending on how you look at it
yeah it's not technically a DLC it's
called a necromancer pack but I mean it
just depends on how you wanna like
whatever you want to call it right DLC
is like downloadable contents I mean
you're paying for it it's an expansion
expansion pack not even expansion factor
that's not true we'll just call the
necromancer pack because I don't want to
call it the wrong way I don't ever want
to see the truth in this game please
know I hated him I thought that I really
wanted to do it and then I played it and
then I was like no I really wish this
character maybe I'm being harsh I don't
know I was just never a fan of the dude
let me use my tornados
and where is the density
oh yeah it supposed to change your
insight oh come on we want the other
grim size skill oh it's kind of cool
though there's a 5% chance that you can
insta kill oh my god it's even shorter
dude this range is like ridiculously
short
damn you can spam definite over the holy
crap
okay for all the people that are saying
like ripoff whatever I again value
proposition it's totally up to the
person in terms of oh no I'm gonna die
in terms of like how you spend your
money what you spend your money on it's
it's not it's not a ripoff if you don't
buy it
like you don't have to just you're still
getting a the new zones the challenge
rifts you're getting all of that stuff
the only thing is if you want to play
the necro it's 15 dollars like the whole
conversation about DLC or phantom packs
or whatever again it's totally up to you
to spend that money if you find it
valuable then it's worth it if you don't
want to buy it
alright you have to remember how much
free stuff Blizzard has given in terms
of like Diablo 3 and even like Diablo 2
all these updates have been free
assuming you you know you bought the
base game and the expansion the one
expansion that's come out like kanai's
cube itself could have been like you
could have well I don't think it was
enough to be like okay this is an
expansion pack but I mean it was
game-changing so yeah that's the end of
that argument for me
that seems to be such a big deal for
them people won't know we killed the
wrong one
I'm sure how I feel about this AoE
skeletal mages I knew there for grim
sizes as a you try siphon blood that's
the only thing we haven't tried yet oh
here's a two hand oh god it sucks
nope we're not using that we'll try
siphon blood bloodsucker or what is this
do you pull in health globes okay let's
go back to that devourer gives you life
back okay try this skill sure
try let's go
also I guess some iPhone brought up
another thing you could try is a path of
Exile is a free-to-play game
oh that's where equals go
so the way that works is it takes core
plants it takes this like the corpses
and then it shoots shows at the pretty
cool big in it it looks visually
pleasing as well
Wow okay Forrest's - blood works fun
we got bone armor bone armor is cool too
because it's not like your traditional
d2 bone armor it actually puts like a no
there's no corpses near I think that's
why the name trigger
yeah okay or no enemies near you can't
play d3 offline David at least not on PC
you can on console I believe I think you
can play offline on console
without any uses Philip thank you for
the information and if you guys are
checking I need to do it our maintenance
are starting 15 minutes I don't know
it looks like 50 minutes for you so
let's try to get bone armor there you go
now I look like this
that's pretty cool I like that it's like
the Crusader buff where they turn crazy
looking
her plan seems pretty good
refresh our bone armor
Lord Dec saying he'd rather play pay for
a D to remake them this DLC hey I would
- to be honest I really I really loved
ET played a lot in high school and
college some and I would love a D -
romantic play if and when is gonna
happen you know I mean there's
speculation of course hence any necro is
out on PC so if you're playing on PC
necro is lease out on PC in terms of in
us might not be out yet in
like in that blood
thank you for the kind words
that clitoris and I'm not sucking blood
out of a skeleton necessarily sticky
chicken unless in that moment I was
fighting a skeleton in which case who
knows
these are named okay
and it's summoner but his stuff
those are those are new these these
things are new like whatever is casting
those well like hydro looking things
this is a clearly have a new boss really
mmm the other ones better though
yeah I don't care where the Bloods
coming from man I just need to you know
drink our blood
shoot those corpse Lance's I just got
here I failed hydras first
yeah like a lizard people yeah the Earl
is a people
oh this is like a big-ass crab I know
the realms do end because the other ones
we were just going through those ended
so they definitely do end I I do like
this though more because it keeps
changing the environments I guess it's
kind of like a greater rift or I mean
kind of like rifting but cool to see
some of these new enemy types with these
stupid material water looking hydras I
don't wish the mages to stayed active
this version of the mages works pretty
well though because it leaves behind a
corpse and then you can need a corpse
explode or corpse Lance oh I think we
ever did our other passive so now we
have standalone increased 100% armor
bite weight increase our 100% reduced by
10% for each active minion it's not so
great because I have a bunch of people
that are bunch of minions that's pretty
good yeah and go with that attack speed
can't get ice golem yet
I do a corpse explode I'm gonna go back
to corpse explode real quick we can try
the archers if you guys want to see that
so now we're in the lab I think they're
ice elemental the archers corpse explode
is by far as still one of the coolest
looking the skills
the three necro
it's like you feel the impacts of it all
siphon that blood
Oh what is it
I don't need gold
oh no oh no we're gonna be chasing this
goblin forever now we got Waypoint
kill the kill the Goblin
all right we got him
I'll rip those days when you rip those
days they're not that they weren't that
long uh yeah I mean Digital daylight
you're not wrong that people are gonna
be level 70 before he hits Europe but I
mean there's no new season right so like
technically if I wanted to I could have
moved all my gear over and like made my
neck or like really buff but I just want
to experience this as if I had nothing
and it was like day one because like I'm
not like so interested in the fact that
like oh I want to be like super Oh whew
right now I mean no it's just like the
end of this y know Templar I just forgot
to hire them crazy chicken penguin I
mean I can go get on them once we go
back to town it's a good point though
why does the necro or why did Blizzard
release the neck right between season
that's a good question crestfallen I
have no idea maybe they wanted to get
more people back playing necro see what
the balancing was is like because I know
they did you know they obviously had
their rounds of beta but maybe they want
to see the stuff that people do with the
necro and then further test and balance
before the next season so that you know
they get a good grasp of how the Necker
will play out for that season I mean I
guess that makes sense
[Music]
labyrinth
here's to almost be over with we shall
see
yeah I mean I'm not even using my
Paragon right now again that's part of
the luxury of it not being a new season
so hen sent me asking me why are you
playing on expert and not on something
like torment 3 the reason why is because
when I tried playing torment just now it
was too difficult for the gear that I
had and it's not a very good viewing
experience for you guys if I am
struggling to kill stuff obviously so
that's why I'm not playing at a higher
level right now I mean I can try bumping
it back to calm that one again or like
master but I have a bad feeling about it
like I don't have that much agir right
now you can barely kill anything an
expert it's kind of true
and I mean for all those people that
play Diablo you guys know it's all about
efficiency and stuff like that so you
never play or I never play a harder
difficulty if it's not efficient and
fast because what's the point at that
like you're just wasting time I don't
think there's anything else
or did I just go can we do that already
should we do this one should go to town
actually I mean if they make a Diablo
for which they have to at some point I
would prefer it to not necessarily be
like this I'd want it to be more like I
don't know if you guys have seen a game
called lineage eternal but it's by
ncsoft and it it basically is kind of
taking some of the Diablo elements but
also adding in like MMO elements as well
so it's like an MMO a RPG which I really
want to play that game just to see what
that's like
I shouldn't have broke everything huh
should have kept that stuff for our
minyan here but that's fine
oh man torches let's see like I have
4,000 charts to which you know we can
use later but think we do yeah we did
this already all right why don't we do
[Music]
you guys want a rift I mean Justin I
don't I can't debate that but I just I
want to play that game though you know
is what it is I want it to be more not
necessarily like an MMO but like it'd be
cool to have like a RPG that's like set
in like a bigger world where you see
different people you have like world
events bigger areas you know that's what
I want to see
well
yeah see this is why we're not going to
master cuz I can't even kill this stuff
although I don't feel like I have the
best damage dueling skills like I should
5 you running like bones here
I just find minions to be probably like
nope I don't do as much damage as you
think so like you get rid of that see if
this goes faster there's one spear skill
have I tried POA yes I played a lot of
peoe a while ago I haven't played as
much more recently but I watch POA
streamers and it definitely is an
interesting game and there's a lot of
good there there's a lot of good ideas
I think races is a cool idea that can
get people to you know play in short
spurts
I like how they always continue to
change and evolve they're like new
seasons or their ladders you know like
it's it's nice to see the greater rifts
and stuff like that but I really enjoy
seeing people race and Keowee because
you know they're there min maxing you
know there's obviously some luck
involved but you know they're min maxing
they are they can check the leaderboards
they can see like you can see how tight
the experience between you know first
second and third are and I don't know
there's some pretty good stuff there and
that's a free-to-play game yeah and I
think everything that's if anything is
the pace stuff is just for cosmetics so
that's a really nice touch so goodbye
GGG Keowee was our PC game of the year
like I think was it like three years ago
and I was I hope kind of advocate that a
little bit
wasn't just me obviously cuz it's
GameSpot as a whole but it was one of
the games I remember kind of fighting
for and
are you asking me if POA is better than
g3 I don't know I always have this like
special place for d3 in my heart and I
think visually d3 looks better I get
that path of Exile is kind of going for
that darker style that like almost looks
like a pink too in a way sort of but
visually the skills and the impact and
just know something about that it makes
the avila feel like really cool to me
like just watching like this corpse
explode I mean there's a lot of
abilities and effects in path of Exile
as well but yeah something about Diablo
3 for me
maybe I'm just like I mean wizard fanboy
or something
and what are you what do you guys think
for the people that are going to have
played both
[Music]
I mean it's it's I get that you don't
want to necessarily talk about comparing
it just in but I mean it's fair to
compare them they have similarities I
think it's it's healthy to talk about
you know both games just to give people
and informs kind of perspective of like
games that are out games you can play
and I think sometimes like you know like
it's good to have those conversations
too because you like wizard learns from
them grinding Gear games learns from
Diablo and it's like it's all like a
good I played grim Don as well I don't
know like I couldn't like there was
there's some good there but I just
couldn't get like into it into it I gave
it a go I even gave um and what was that
other game there's another game I gave
then house or like was it van Helsing or
one of the like there was a a RPG that
was like van Helsing and I gave that a
try too and that was just didn't work
out for me either I guess increase the
damage dealt to increases the damage
dealt to 145 damage we could try army of
the Dead but it's look like a really
long cooldown skill I'll just show it to
you guys in your oh wait you guys wanted
to get as many minions as possible right
so let's see we can can get back those
skeleton
like here we're gonna try to summon as
much stuff as possible we have revived
now they don't always revive with your
gold Oh unless they changed it but
sometimes it'll just revive skeleton
right now it revived all the skeletons
we can get the goat guys - there's a
timer on them they last for 15 seconds
and I think it's what up to 10
so we got the spiders that's cool
oh yeah Marvel heroes as well for those
who know who like Diablo 2 or epic work
on that Marvel heroes I played that as
well fun game
i streamed Marvel hero stream well a
long time ago with Brevik and it was
really cool I was like nerding out a
little bit my fam going out is kind of
nerve-wracking but really cool same time
really happy to have the opportunity
always got to remember to be grateful to
be able to do what I do and you guys
helped support that really appreciate it
guys
Havenhurst I am in America that's how
I'm playing you know obviously without
you guys and your support we wouldn't be
able to do what we do here against five
and we are all appreciative for you guys
to grow
oh my minions please so I guess you
could have what is it like six skeletons
a golem ten revives and five mages
someone do the math on that and fifteen
twenty one twenty two mobs I guess I
guess I still not as much as a witch
doctor right because they can have the
the fetishes or maybe it's close by like
pretty close
some people saying he's not released yet
hopefully it comes out soon for you guys
we're sorry that it's not out at the
same time I know we just wanted a circle
cyborg I guess it just came out earlier
in the u.s. apologies that you know it's
not out in the EU yet but hopefully you
get to play it as soon as it's out also
you know again there's not a new season
so I mean other than the fact of not
being able to play at the same time
nothing nothing too detrimental I mean I
would be a little upset too though not
being able to play right now oh this is
this looks new I don't know if it
actually isn't you but it kind of looks
new
like in this bone armor though I guess
the one I chose made me look red
Oh sick if they give me the the couch
the couch
those guys are super annoying all right
we got some of the pestilence guys to
you now you will help me
Oh minions I hate fighting
starting to get some gems which is good
I'm gonna put that in there level up
faster put this in our pants it's more
damaged
yeah July 11th or July 20th will be when
season 11 comes out as duck yours is
mentioned
revive is sweet yeah that's pretty sweet
I can't wait to get some maybe we can
gamble for some light on a little bit
try to get like you know like tasker's
or something some stuff to make our pets
do more damage good I don't know feels
like cheating at that point if I do that
like a little bit
kargh three fighters is a positive 15 so
it's like close right that's actually
that's 26 but that's the guard three is
with the ring right that's with short
man and then there's like the three dogs
I haven't seen all of the necro
legendary so I'm not sure if the any of
the necro legendary is like it gives you
like another coal one more anything like
that yeah as evening guard build was
pretty good I played that last season I
usually play the seasons like a little
bit for a couple days and then you can
get geared up pretty quickly and then I
don't really have the patience to
necessarily make another character and
then it becomes like mid Maxine you're
trying to get your travelers plaid to
combo and stuff which at ancients
I got a star medal when like it didn't
matter like great that's what I need
starting that all could never get start
mental before decides to give it to me
what I do you really don't
don't cheat alright well not cheap
sounds good Frank keep me honest chat
that's what I need then you know set to
let you revive like old like I'm revived
a boss like old-school active d too high
or like when you would make an iron
golem out of like like a ethereal do TV
rather the dime those were the days
right
speaking of which what are the necro
unique ear sight off handful atrophy and
then there's a two-hand sight I think
that's it unless I'm mistaken
yeah did I miss the tea to all the good
and the bad of it
dude my mic coolest dt2 moment was me
and my buddy were just mewling gear and
you know like this was when Diablo phone
existed and it's like counting downside
is whatever and like literally as we're
mewling you get that we get the prompt
like okay Diablo clone is in your game
and I'm like holy [ __ ] dude get back in
the game right now
stop mewling deep diablo clones here and
then that's how we got our awesome find
my highlight a few oh we got a goblet
[ __ ] are you serious we got a goblin
rift at night there's no way I hold on
there's no way I'm killing this stuff
I'm lowering it too hard because I don't
know how we're gonna kill this stuff I
did not plan for this please please kill
them
I don't even know where they're all at
kill them No
a feeling this is not a good idea just
kill these two no no there's not time
for the rift guardian there's more
treasure to be had
go No
wait there was another one right get his
ass
No
all right they were there they're a
little bit more generous now about the
goblins so I guess we kind of lucked out
there sorry I had to lower it there was
no way we were gonna kill all those
goblins oh wait I still hear one that
was worth though guys that was worth I
mean we didn't get everything but we got
a we got a kid we got a good little good
little spread here for what we could
kill that's pretty fun yeah that's not
laughing hey man when you the worst
feeling man is is doing see knowing that
you get a goblin rift and then you don't
have the deeps to to kill them because
you're too weak it's like the worst
feeling 100% when you see that on t13
you [ __ ] your pants that is true that's
when you got to just start lowering the
difficulty man because there's no point
if you can't kill them real talk
worth yes it was it was worth see you
like one got away here like you just see
all the little gold that it's like the
little goblin that could have been if
you just could have killed him you know
Danny my family
RIF Guardium up come Nephilim come to
your dad a player Collins Kelvin to kill
them all no I don't care about the I
don't care about the rift guardian at
that point let's see if there's another
level
I don't know here's another question for
you guys like do you finish the rift or
do you guys just kind of go through and
like kill the rift guardian and then
just like ours now I don't know
anything's better than what he's using
now right alright we got this we got to
get out of here so we can up the
difficulty
let's close that up leave the game I can
do some story if you guys want not sure
if you guys want to see story or not
let's try let's try tor man again I
doubt I can do it but you know we'll
lower it one Goblin a day keeps the evil
ways that's business
I like that digging that alright so how
are we looking
we don't have an amulet I guess we could
we could buy one I would assume this
buying a dis oh I definitely okay wait
it's crafting buying doesn't count as
cheating right because I have I don't
think buying is a unfair cuz this is
seven thousand gold I could have
afforded that I have way more damage I
don't think I don't think buying house
is cheating because I would have did
this regardless
yeah I don't think there's any unique
armor types other than it's okay if you
bicep will forgive you
all right nothing like being forgiven
super vitality with the socket sure it's
only six thousand gold I could have
definitely afforded that there I'll show
you guys that that knee area again in
case some of you guys didn't get to see
it
oh wait we didn't do shrouded mores
here's the other area I mean idiot
that's right I said to myself there's a
new this is a new area - oh that guy is
this the guy that betrayed us later and
was like we're gonna become closer okay
you didn't do that much effort but uh oh
we got a party over there it's a ping
party okay these are all new minions
let's see if I can do Foreman it's kind
of not looking that way though all right
we finally killed one
all right not happening not gonna waste
our time let's try master also it does
not look like it's happening there's
something like liking that guy's going
crazy
all right so we got we got werewolves
lichens where we're currently watching
underworld where's Kate Beckinsale's
okay so these guys look like Dodos that
are like you know spitting acid
that hunger is so great that's cool so
it looks like revive is reviving like
all this stuff now we got like birds
like vultures what's going on here cult
this party oh you can have six skeletal
archers throw away no that's just a plop
isn't it
oh my attack speed nice oh the blood
mother what the hell is that
Oh should I've not done that
okay whoopsie daisies just woke up the
blood mother
hey I like our little revive is like
this like weird Joe sleeping
that's it what expected more than that
in that girl live Gustav is live in the
u.s. I don't know if it's live in Europe
yet yeah what a party crasher right yeah
that's what I do you know you call this
party or like hey dudes want to hang out
you way better than the other streamer
oh well thanks Frank that's really nice
of you all right
resplendent this is like the one time
when you're like playing well not that
one time but I feel like respondents
aren't as good as they seem except for
like when you're first starting and you
need rare items after that they're just
like oh I don't think I'm ever gonna get
any gear from this what's the point
oh we just got a necklace that's an
upgrade that's good and shoulder upgrade
okay okay seriously now have but I buy
it blood rush but we are so gimped right
now that yeah I'm trying to summon as
many necros as possible or necrose
summons as possible currently we have
six at six or seven seven skeletons a
golem we can do up to ten revives and
five with these skeletal mages with our
archers for me right now
[Music]
yeah so this is kind of like what it
looks like to have like almost pull
Arsenal if I can some of these mages
fasten everything it's kind of a lot of
stuff
oh we got bone spirit if you guys want
to see that I think bone spirit doesn't
work like the old bone spirit I think it
like that's like a llama we can check it
out in a second after we clear the
shrouded Moors so at least we can do
master now that's pretty good
couldn't do that earlier so we're making
progress guys did I play on PTR is what
the and asked me I did play some beta
PTR I stopped before they actually had
necro weapons and off hands so I did try
out the sets but it was kind of
meaningless to try out the sets when you
didn't have the weapons and stuff
because I don't know they weren't doing
as much as I thought they would weapons
and off hands is kind of really what
makes it that in cubing items horse
yep no worries thanks for stopping by
hopefully you stay around if not no
worries appreciate you coming anyways
appreciate all you guys being here today
with me checking out the necro some new
areas talking ARPGs the good the bad the
ugly oh is it you really not the one
safe
whoa you guys are like eight hours head
so like in two more hours that seems
kind of like a long time well I'm glad
that all you e you folks are hanging out
with me then what too late for you guys
it we're getting there right come on we
need dead bodies
maybe we can't do masters so it's taking
a while to kill
maybe that's just to pack
like one
the season over yes is currently over
it'll be back on the 20th of July
let's revive personal army
I think anything's gonna be better than
what we have right now so damage taking
is reduced by 1% great
we don't necessarily care about that we
can I could show you guys the ice golem
now it's kind of cool
he just like a roll instead oh yeah you
can something like one buff skeletal
mage to let's its enemies they're slowed
try that try I guess we're going cold
element or ice now I have ice archers I
oh it's kind of cool that it's still
kind of blood siphon even though it's
icy icy blood
thanks for stopping by a digital
daylight gaming and hope that if you
were gonna buy the necro or having we're
thinking about it that you enjoy - but
really appreciate you stopping by and
chatting and hanging out and what's
different about these wolves their hands
are on fire but why oh this one's too
angry that one
so the active oh because a frost Nova
that's different I could've sworn he did
a role in PTR but I guess he does like a
thing where he freezes everything around
me it's pretty cool
this has to be better than whatever's
what's going on there another blood
mother call this party oh oh this is I
know I want to see that guy look at dude
look at him he's like gyrating he's
being tortured we gotta save him
Hemet ich father Feldman is a bad person
he was torturing that man oh he's still
being tortured
dude are you okay sir oh I freedom
did I really free him though he doesn't
look like he's that oh I don't know and
these cultists are pretty pretty
perverse
there's the the net a Pedro 666 the
necromancer is a necromancer pack you
have to pay $15 one or her but it comes
with some other stuff as well that I
mentioned earlier you get this icon or
banner you get a banner as well the
wings the wings I have equipped right
now those are also part of the pack you
get to stash tabs to more heroes to
stash tabs are only on PC though just so
you guys know you have to pay to get the
necro guys $15 if you don't already own
it on console you could buy the $40
version which gives you everything plus
the necro which is a pretty good deal
$14.99 our 15 euro as Mohsen
I said your name mostly correct feel
like I've been butchering the elevator
and also it doesn't appear that the
necro is out in Europe yet so started
those folks but I'm happy in a way
because then you guys are here hanging
out with me instead
that's me being selfish though I kind of
what you guys play in the neck thank you
though
alright is this another area perhaps no
do we finish the shot in Moore's because
I mean those two things we just saw
where part of the trailer that they
showed I'm kind of hoping that it's a
little bit bigger
Imelda you're the first person that has
said 15 euros to most of the people are
not very happy that they have to pay $15
for the next I think that is the end of
the shrouded Wars guys oh wait I mean we
can check this corner but I highly doubt
they got to free stash tabs as long as
you're on PC Oh another cultist
and he has that Diablo skill actually I
think necro has that too one of the
passes makes it so that you could
technically imprison stuff but you uh
it's like a proc though how do I not get
the ghosts I do
Wow he died so fast what the hell
happened to him okay he wasn't the last
boss he wasn't in the endgame a lot of
blood I'm currently in America for the
person that just asked what region I was
playing in
Toshio Toshio and hello sir uh-oh sample
the firstborn who is the firstborn
though oh now we're in the firstborn
heir okay dang it alright well at least
you get to see this area do that
Oh my boat armor don't fade bone armor
I guess I'm gonna be reviving a lot of
cockroaches
cockaroach party ooh I got these
weird-looking nudes now
I look so weird
hey dude turn around this way dude that
those guys look freaky I'm the first
four instead of ggb 86 and then Elijah
vandal Walker says he's the second who
was the third then
we trigger
oh yeah this is cool
those guys are gonna do the chickpeas
hopefully we can summon them and revive
but it wasn't there like a door to
something else feel like they're boys Oh
No
oh these guys explode
I thought this was purely game playing
you're joking right
feel like you're trolling feel like
you're jolla trolling so close to me why
you guys do dad
I know I like seeing the light bar
though maybe that's just me
and that ice golem freezes pretty clutch
but better that Covey there's
technically new content there's a you
have to new regions more than two
actually
oh my god hold on hold on we're getting
infested right now
okay the roaches are real there's two
new areas and then on top of that
obviously a new class and also the
seasons not out yet as well as I mean
technically some of that stuff's free
like the challenge rift and all that
stuff is like technically free so I
guess you could argue part of that
again having a little bit of an insect
problem
try not to die again it's been a while
since we died but yeah there's gonna be
a new season obviously coming up
it's family for the class
hmm we got new one-handed site pulls a
new passive
well we finally got Wow it'd take a
little 13 euro rush I probably won't be
getting blood rushed for now because I
feel like we need as many skills as you
can for damage but we will check out the
passive slot see the vein thing
please give us some more
lunar 7 saying they are enjoying in the
new class quite a bit
awesome glad you could tune in alright
that's true I can I can't argue with
that BOTS could be it is kind of
expensive in the sense that like if you
played a lot of Diablo and you're only
really getting the necro it is kind of
like an expensive potentially expensive
proposition to only get 10 necro is
yeah core of what you're getting but you
know that is not more damage yeah as I'm
playing this more and more I do feel
some of the differences I mean of course
we're gonna share some of the same
styles but necro definitely does feel
like it has its own place in the world
and I do like that the active abilities
more than the witchdoctor where the pets
aren't as active they're just kind of
doing whatever at least here you can
kind of control them a little bit more
truly the commander of the Dead as it
were man there's just a lot of these
insects
don't know how I feel about that you
know I the people have been here you
know I hid the bees these guys are not
as painful all the odd King did not mean
to use the cool down on the ice : $15.00
could be a lot for some people respect
the fact that like it's cheap for
everyone in a fantasy also you have to
keep a factor in like there's a lot of
games that people are playing
potentially thinking about buying steam
summer sales out you know $15 would go a
long way especially it's something like
the steam summer sale you could get
three or four quality games right now I
think like shadow of Mordor was like
five dollars there's like that and that
game probably would last you like 2030
plus hours of following I mean just
because $15 is nothing to you doesn't
mean that $15 is not a lot to someone
else so I would just say respect that
it's nice that maybe you have $15 and
you know like that nothing to you but
yeah let's just be respectful you think
that goes anywhere hmm
Chris necromancer is out in the US
apparently not out in EU yet
Soto's kun again it's all about like is
it worth it to you right like someone's
best example earlier was like if you go
watch a movie right it's probably gonna
cost you close to $15 am I gonna get
more entertainment out of this than a
movie
potentially a movies about two hours two
and a half hours I might get five hours
of entertainment out of this is all of
it gonna be necessarily fun maybe not
because there's gonna be some grinding
involve obviously but when I get to that
end end game the loot and I start you
know mid maxing my gear and just like
you know like speeding through riffs and
stuff like that I think it's gonna be a
lot of fun for me personally now again
that doesn't necessarily mean it's gonna
be fun for everyone else but me it's
worth it and for others it's working but
just depends I'm sorry if I'm rereading
the same thing for some of the people
that are in the chat but I feel like
it's an important thing to talk about oh
you know what we have skills that we
haven't used
face maximum oh we can increase them
duration of our I don't know is it just
revived and skeletal mages awesome
[Music]
I am with you there but but could be I
wish there was like a new zone kind of
like but I don't know kind of like when
the Crusader came out that would have
been cool just have like a new zone but
I mean at the same time reversals was
$40 package and this is 15
Simon also bring out the fact that a
skin and League of Legends could be $7
yeah again it's just value proposition
how you spend your money what you want
caused a lot more damage
come on we need some cultists
so this is one of the key areas this
this is kind of cool to me I mean it's
like a small touch but like we're
killing cultists filling blood that then
opens this door like that's pretty cool
to me and now we're gonna get back to
being infested this place has a serious
roach problem all right just one mint
hook it up
could we roll that
[Music]
oh you mean that top left are you
talking about this I don't know that
does look a little suspect I didn't even
notice that because I just never look up
there I guess
all right same to my blood
[Music]
nothing to revive yet but I think he
does someone adds CP okay
where are those where do please
I like siphoned blood because it's a
very lazy skill I can just left wait
if I get some these corpses
[Music]
so much power
we did add that was good
whoo that was good too all right we got
in town there's a cow level I'd not
necessarily there technically is a color
hmm okay so
all righty let's see let's try some new
skills out shall we
oh what's this
now I would die here's the worst uh so
you show you army of the Dead
it's a pretty long cooldown though yeah
it's fine show you bone a blood rush
it's like the teleport and do we have
blood no but yet no blood no is level 57
okay
show you bone spirit so you're like you
only get so many charges you gain a
charge every 15 seconds and can store up
to three recharge time is reduced by the
one second for each corpse you consume
okay so we need to consume corpses
somehow we can't do army and maybe you
don't need blood rush then let's see
devour I'll show you guys to Bower -
it's like you
which is factored okay let's uh let's
give this a go I might not be able to do
master with this weird thing that I'm
gonna try now you're probably hung on
let's switch this to phone spirit I'm
sorry the hotkeys it's easier if I do
this okay
let's see how this goes this is a good
thing II to again
oh hello oh we got another Lee orcs a
newer one all right oh sure
open a rock get a new helm all right so
this is
Landa the charm whoa oh my god it's
raining Legendary's that was army of the
dead I guess this one doesn't do the
thing oh wow
we just go all damage that's fine so
devourer would be that so you eat on the
game life back
here's bones spirits three charges but I
think if we eat some corpses yep
reduces the cooldown it's good
I don't know how much damage that's
doing though the recharge time seems
pretty long
I don't know corpses take my bone
spirits oh dang
hey it kills like one thing like really
fast but that's about it
have just joined Peter sauce she says
you might have brought some luck thanks
man I appreciate it
are those bony spirits
whoa okay I didn't feel it damn it I
thought it like toasted that a rare mom
but I don't think it did
[Music]
wait did it kill it in one hit oh my god
it's so many rares over here all right
we'll be okay we're gonna get our cool
down here in a second hopefully
I did like hat okay we're gonna army of
the Dead here I didn't even see it
happen but stuff died
I think it does a lot of damage the bone
spirit 4000 damage like it did like
half-life 2 that rare there's another
arrow down here somewhere okay here's a
blue here's a blue oh yeah I did like
half but the problem is I only have
three of them didn't really do anything
any more corpses just like oh no oh
that's not that bad I guess like I
needed to like AoE or something it only
hits one target
yeah it doesn't cap but at the rate I'm
getting the damage it's like not fast
enough
oh I know it targeted the wrong thing so
yeah I don't know if I'm a fan
Oh another legendary let's go get height
raining stars must be because it's
rewarding me for testing new business
that's fine not why black art is black
our burdens away Honda five minutes so
you can play sick nice alright more
damage sure more damage five minutes
some people saying they continued in
their store awesome glad you guys can
finally see it in your store
what time do we start we started like at
1:00 huh yeah I think I mean since most
of you guys at EU with the patch that's
coming online I'm really glad you guys
stuck with me and hung out I'm just
gonna finish this riff for all those
people watching they look like Holliday
we could recap a little bit but uh bone
Spears seems okay if you can find a way
to like get the bone spear back fast
enough I haven't been able to do
it's something
we're gonna use that land of the dead
for like half life it's still doing
damage poison it's pretty cool
he you patches online sick he'll get it
guys if you've been waiting for it go
get it
alright so we'll just get out of here
that was it that was a pretty good one
three Legendary's from one the first top
area it's pretty good Oh another
legendary why is it all weapons though I
need I need some armors like come on
come on game fine black art looks cooler
the impact on bone spirits pretty cool
though
the awkward thing is like I don't know
what - yeah I thought there'd only it's
like one thing
but you need like we would need
something to like kill I guess we
wouldn't use this skill would use
something else and then you'd use bone
skill to kill like the rift guardian I'm
looking at a chat box more than the
video that's fine sometimes that's what
the experience about Tina
hoping how slow the bone fear goes oh
did he even hit oh it finally finally
found its way watch it
look at it struggle to get to the mom
you can do it skeleton that is hilarious
how long it took to get there devourer
is pretty cool though look at how far
the radius what or the range was on that
devourer go get it cries less than one
megabit downwards Oh someone saying the
patch is maybe 2.9 gigs
some people saying restarting the
launcher let's wall to to get it to see
it
clearly going wrong
someone saying I think motion is from
confirming the 2.9 if gig requirement
do we really go the absolute wrong way
pallets that way I don't think it's been
four years since they released a new
character pretty sure Crusader was lot
sooner than four years let me say so
like people also don't factor in this is
way too da saying that people don't
factor in the fact that you got kanai's
cube and all these other all these other
free updates for free until now I think
people underestimate the value of that
and I think it's insane that they do
but hey what do I know
another confirmation of 2.9 gigs thank
you Valentine
I guess I could be smiling more but you
know this is my farming face feel
serious also trying to reach at
also because my ability right now the
way I expected my neck rope is like not
that active it takes like a kind of
saving of army of the dead and bone
spirit just so I can do big beeps
because then I don't know the cooldown
seems pretty long like watch we're gonna
do it
hopefully here
yeah cool down
I think it's more my spec than anything
it's like I have two abilities I can
kill and my minions aren't doing as much
damage well that's fair man how have I
knock on the rift guardian yeah I've
gone to four levels hopefully we have
army of the dead by the time rift
guarding although I think three bone
spirits is finding me enough to kill the
rift guardian ah master although I guess
we're gonna have to use it on this guy
get there it's the slowest attack
all right where is he no we still have
army of the Dead oh she just teleported
here all right let's see one bond spirit
through bone spirits okay I guess she's
not dying three
we need army of the Dead oh my god where
did all this stuff come from I don't
remember her doing that attack either
the poisons maybe that's me were
oh we're okay we're okay we're gonna get
her BAM
army to the dead the rest of this stuff
alright we did it we did a chat at some
dice ring got some new pants
so yeah boy spirit was interesting I'm
not gonna use em anymore what do we have
on right-click earlier I [ __ ] revive
revive was more fun to me I don't want
to fear high school was pretty cool bone
armor bone armor is pretty good too
oh yeah that's kind of what I was will
switch back to extended servitude this
this skill we had skeletal mages but
anyways that is kind of just a little
taste of necromancer I know that it's
finally out in the EU for you guys over
there so I hope you guys enjoy playing
the necromancer for those of you who are
interested in buying it again 1499 u.s.
dollars 15 euro I believe for the
necromancer you're mainly just getting
the necromancer you are getting two new
zones you're also getting the challenge
rifts in the 2.6 patch some of that that
stuff is also just free if you don't
want to buy the necromancer so you can
also just enjoy and play that well for
the 15 dollars you're getting the let's
show you guys some of that stuff you're
getting the wings which are these wings
the wings of the Crypt Guardian oh I
guess that ran out of space anyways the
the wings of the Crypt Guardian which is
pretty cool you're also getting a new
pet this half form golem this guy right
here and then you're also getting a
portrait that for some reason makes my
character look like a I think someone in
chat said twelve year old little boy I
don't know why that looks so bad but
that the icon
portrait frame was cool and then the
pennant of blood master pennants yeah
it's pretty cool it's got skull the top
so those things as well as two
additional character slots and two
stashed abs but the stashed abs are only
for PC not console and the only other
thing I would say is if you haven't
played on console at all
and you've been thinking about playing
Diablo 3 or Reaper souls there's a
pretty good deal that lets you get the
necromancer as well as the rest of the
stuff it's called Diablo 3 eternal
collection you get a you know it's all
in one package you get ultimate evil
edition and the rise of the necromancer
pack for a special price right now
that's $39.99 it's going to eventually
go up to 59.99 but thanks everybody for
tuning in to today's stream if you
haven't hit subscribe rate please do so
that really helps us out to inform you
guys when we do live streams we do live
streams every day at 11 a.m. Monday to
Friday tomorrow we'll have the lobby our
weekly talk show at 11 a.m. and then
we're gonna have I believe a lawbreaker
stream after that at 2 p.m. tomorrow
that's Wednesday Pacific time Thursday
we're gonna have another stream with
Joey and John Luke and then Friday of
course Zelda breath of the wild the
master Trials DLC will be out so Peter
and Rob will kind of be bring Triforce
back for like one episode they're gonna
play for four hours or hopefully around
4 hours of that DLC so if you're
interested in that you know stay tuned
for that but uh again thanks everybody
and I will see you guys next time and
gals